hey i'm back with another video today
we're going to talk about statins
okay it is very very essential for you
to understand this information
now statins work by blocking a certain
enzyme that blocks your production of
cholesterol
your liver cells make a good amount of
cholesterol in your body
so the cholesterol in your body is not
just coming from the diet
it's coming from your own cells and it
has some very important purposes
number one it's a precursor for making
bile salts which is involved in
digesting fats
absorbing fat cypo vitamins like vitamin
a
e d k omega 3 fatty acids
etc etc cholesterol is also necessary in
making bile salts
so if you don't have enough bile salts
your risks for
gall stones go up your risk for
pancreatitis increases
because if you have bile sludge that's
going to block the pancreatic ducts
and causing a back up into the pancreas
so there's so many side effects of
statin but the big one
is myopathy now that's a gentle term for
muscle disease
because statins have a direct effect on
the muscle
they can create necrosis of the muscle
which basically kills the muscle
they can cause muscle cell apoptosis
which is another term
for the muscle cells dying you can get
all sorts of inflammatory
muscle problems weakness of the muscle
pain
in the muscle stiffness in the muscle
and even an autoimmune condition of the
muscle as well
another side effect is high levels of
something called
creatinine kinase which indicates muscle
wasting
and that can increase by 10x now there's
also the topic of why your cholesterol
is high in the first place and
let's say it even goes up is there any
problem with having high cholesterol
i'm going to leave that for another
video but in this video i want to talk
to the person who's on statins
and what you can do to reduce
the symptoms of myopathy now there's
something else that
a statin will deplete and that is
something called
coq10 it's an enzyme involved
in giving your muscles energy and you
may have seen it
at the healthy store mainly for heart
problems
if you're deficient in coq10
you get muscle wasting muscle weakness
low back pain
again a problem in the muscle um heart
failure and the list goes on and on and
on so the more statin you take
the more deficient in coq10 you're going
to be
and it just happens that if you take
coq10
you can greatly diminish the symptoms of
myopathy
when someone's on a statin drug so this
video is mainly about
those people that are taking statins
that apparently for some reason have to
take it
they're getting side effects and they
might not know
how simple it is to relieve the
complications
from this medication so start taking
coenzyme q10
and if i were you i would double or
triple the dosage if you're taking the
statin
and as you're coping with statins i
would highly recommend you also learn
more about cholesterol how to keep it in
check
and what diet you need to be on if
you're new to my channel i put the links
down right there
check it out before you go
if you have a question about a product
or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the u.s
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help